[Musik]
hallo herr flowers of any weltweite gibt
ein richtig traditionelle teppich wert
nämlich apfelstrudel machen und leckerem
apfelstrudel einmal mit und einmal ohne
rosinen und apfelstrudel ansicht vieler
gewinnt jetzt haben sich viele wünschten
ja unter anderem unser freund rüdiger
bei freund nicht ob mein freund oder
kollegen eher allgemein frank rüdiger
ditz apfelstrudel über alles und
deswegen habe ich gedacht komm ich zeig
euch mal wieder geht der teig ist nicht
so vereinfacht und es ist auch wirklich
ein ganz ganz tolles rezept und ja was
soll ich noch dazu sagen und so ist
kommt aus österreich
naja eigentlich jahr wiener apfelstrudel
aber wir haben sehr viel und wirkt
irgendwie gefügten regen apfelstrudel
wieder okay also nach verliebt
jetzt zeige ich zuerst einmal wie man
den teig herstellen viele denken ja
immer auch von strudel menschen ist kann
ich nicht das muss aus den auf rollen
und so weiter aber das ist wirklich kein
hexenwerk und ich finde auch im strudel
mitgemacht im teig ist auf jeden fall
viel viel leckerer als auch im strudel
mit gekauftem zeigt oder auch mit
blätterteig und deswegen zeige ich euch
jetzt mal die zutaten sind ganz ganz
wenige und die habe ich auch echt immer
im haushalt also hier erst einmal die
zutaten und dann geht es für den teig
brauche ich 250 gramm mehl salz 1 125
warmes wasser 20 und für die füllung
habe ich jetzt hier ein kilo plätze
nämlich 200 gramm butter sahne etwas von
den extrakt nach belieben könnt ihr auch
mobile verwenden
105 luca den halben teelöffel zimt 50
gramm mandelsplitter und 50 und 60 gramm
butter so erzählt ist der teig
hergestellt und den machen jetzt einfach
wieder handelt ihr könnt natürlich auch
eine küchenmaschine verwenden aber auch
mit der hand klappt ist sehr sehr gut
gebt ihr einfach das mehl auf eine
arbeitsfläche da kommt eine kleine mulde
hinein
da konntest als mieter so und das erste
mal bitten verrührt
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich nach und nach immer noch
wasser das so und wenn ich dann nicht
mal mit dem kochlöffel arbeiten kann
nämlich auch die hände
[Musik]
ich brauche es nicht einmal das ganze
wasser ist doch bei mir am anfang noch
ein bisschen großes ei war heißt es auch
möglich sei momentan mit der hand macht
denn so hat man einfach auch gefühl und
der zeigt dass jetzt einfach nicht zu
weich werden aber so ist auch schön
geschmeidig seien ein bis zwei esslöffel
wasser übrig und die kann ich jetzt weg
lassen kommt hier noch öl mittags und
dann wieder zeigt schön geschmeidig
titelt war
[Musik]
und wenn er ein bisschen zu weich ist
einfach noch ein bisschen mehr ihn zu
dem derzeit unter aufteilt ans leben
[Musik]
österreich jetzt glücklich perfekt und
jetzt kann ich ihnen ruhen lassen
dafür gebe ich jetzt hier in schmitten
rein teilen aber vorher in zwei
verfahren ein
denn daraus werden zwei apfelstrudel und
wie können wir jetzt mit diesem öl
bestreichen oder zum beispiel auf
entwachsen bestreuen und die eine kugel
links 4 1 und versprühte damit er wird
etwas fakt fünftel
da auch noch ein pflanzliches fett und
zweite kugel devise einfach daneben
das wird jetzt gleich noch abgedeckt
dann mache ich hier sauber und dann
zeige ich mich die füllung hersteller
[Musik]
weiter geht es mit erfüllung die äpfel
ob ich jetzt bereits geschehen und jetzt
werden so fein gehobelten hier neben
dran das ist übrigens hier von der fa
hallo hallo hallo und jetzt intensiv
eingeholt werden und dafür gibt es
mehrere methoden entweder für die äpfel
und können dann hier das kerngehäuse
rausnehmen
[Musik]
und dann fein hobeln oder ihr lasst dem
apfel im vermischen und mit einem apfel
aus daher das kerngehäuse rausnehmen und
können dann den apfel im ganzen hobel
und später einfach noch viel
[Musik]
was jetzt zu den ersteren jetzt noch
perfekt dazu passt ist etwas
zitronenschale abrede stellte es
natürlich eine unbehandelte zitrone und
harris bereits gewaschen
jetzt gehe ich doch ablieferte und
gleich auf den sack und verhindert
natürlich auch dass sie jetzt für mich
frauen werden
[Musik]
hier kommt facebook armee das so
gemeinsam mit dem zimt dann noch die
mandeln und das ganze jetzt erst einmal
verrührt habe praktisch vergessen
familie muss natürlich in meinen
apfelstrudel auch nicht rein
das wird jetzt alles film verrührt und
die äpfel beziehen wird in wasser durch
den zucker natürlich auch und deswegen
werde ich jetzt hier den bauraum noch
gar nicht dazu geben wenn man erst
später jetzt kann ich das ganze hier
stehen lassen und ich mache jetzt eine
variante mit rufen eine variante ohne
rubin deswegen dass sich die rubin jetzt
auch noch raus lässt ihr aber gleich ein
bisschen apfelsaft einlegen wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr aber zum beispiel auch
oben nehmen dass hier noch gott warten
sodass derzeit eben etwa eine halbe
stunde zeit hatten
deshalb durfte thron und jetzt stehe ich
vor meinem wohnzimmer denn es ist sie
auch sehr hart arbeitsfläche arbeiten
weil ich hier einfach mit dem der platz
habe aber gar nicht schlimm ihr wisst ja
die küche hier wohnen firma da drüben es
gemacht von daher alle tat zurück jetzt
habe ich ein sauberes geschirr tuch und
es ist schon richtig schön gebildet da
kommt jetzt immer mehr drauf damit der
teig nicht klebt dann eine kugel
ihr könnt auch einen riesen apfelstrudel
machen aber ich mache lieber zwei kleine
mich den erfolg zeigt so weit aus wie es
nur geht
[Musik]
an
und jetzt wieder zeit ganz dünn gezogen
strudelteig ihrer seite das heißt wir
nehmen jetzt die hand drücken muss
aufpassen dass ich mich mit den
fingernägeln drankommt den dann reist
der teig und jetzt zieht er ihn mit dem
handrücken mit den fingerspitzen
aufeinander
das war wirklich richtig schön dünn wird
im türkischen gibt übrigens auch ein
ähnliches rezept das heißt kulturell und
wirklich ein bürgerkrieg und da steht
man dann wirklich da rollt mit dem hof
partei keine große platte auf und stehen
da gefühlt 20 frauen um eine runde
mischung oder macht für den teig ebenso
auch empfängern aller rechten link kann
natürlich auch alleine machen aber zu
sagen macht mal spaß erst richtig schön
elastisch
der teig wird zudem sein dass wir mal
zeitpunkt vorverlegt dass man dies durch
lesen kann oder wenn ihr das ipad oder
das handy grund liegt in meiner akte
lesen könnt
[Musik]
da jetzt bestreite ich die platte mit
dem blitz im boot haben
[Musik]
dann kommt sagte bauer die hälfte sein
jetzt rot und die hälfte der abfüllung
und da schaue ich jetzt dass die
flüssigkeit nicht mit rein kommen das
heißt ein bisschen ausdrücken und hier
am rand also überall den rand lassen
[Musik]
und jetzt werden hier einfach mal die
kurzen seiten eingeschlagen soll es
einfach nicht raus
vor allem verstecken wir nur die löcher
zu empfangen sind dann hier oben mit dem
tuch für hilfe und rollt den strudel aus
diesen überschuss herd den nämlich jetzt
im weg und das könnt ihr hier einfach so
mit reinlegen
hella hahm aufwachsen den brauche ich
noch arbeiten
den strudeln und hilfegesuche auf mein
bak warf er ich hab jetzt jahre und der
studie können jetzt eine beliebige form
geben und das entweder gerade oder
bisschen geschwungen und jetzt der
apfelstrudel noch mit der butter
bestrichen
[Musik]
der erste titel ist um auch fertig
deckung jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad heißluft für etwa
30 minuten dazwischen seit mache ich
noch den zweiten
[Musik]
jetzt ist der apfelstrudel fertigung
etabliert gerade noch mithilfe schnee
betreut zu wissen dass zufällig schmidt
und deswegen eignet sich hier besonders
und jetzt morath kann ich installieren
den ein habe ich jetzt schon
angeschnitten bis zur mit oder ohne
rosinen ich hab mir gedacht
mitzuarbeiten selbst anschaffen konnte
man deinen teller sondern wir schon hin
gelebt habe ich ein wenig intelligenz
und eine kugel vanilleeis als ihr könnt
man in der soße oder vanille eis
servieren
ich find vanilla ice camp denn der
studie sehen esse ich gerne warm und
dazu dann wieder kalt und dann kommt das
thema beim globus und einfach keine
konturierung stoffe und deswegen nehme
ich das ganz gerne wenn ich nicht
klappen
dann kehrt vielleicht abstellen ich bin
okay aber nachgelassen erschwert habe
ich möchte meine zuschauer also jetzt
aus die konsistenz child protection
scheme es oder kommt mit einem messer
oder ich mag die variante mit denen sich
leben manchmal gut geschmeckt kugel also
ich finde auch dass sie noch ein
bisschen war nur ganz wenig am betteln
aber bei uns also wir essen fast alles
immer kalt weil die forderung von
fischen kommen und dann wird alles an
den märkten noch nicht zu süß ist ja und
normalerweise macht den morath gar keine
warmen speisen und habe gedacht das
motto schmeck tieren ist aber sehr gut
wenn murat schmeckt dann muss notfalls
ihre sap auch nach machen wollt geht auf
meinem blog auffällig das steht noch mal
alles ganz genau jetzt könnt ihr mal
eure oma oder eure mama oder eure eltern
damit überraschend macht einfach mal
strudelteig selber und bereitet diese
leckere tapas oder rum
also ich will spaß und guten appetit und
richtig cool und das zu wirklich genial
beispiel wein zu teuer ist man im
späteren klassisches
[Musik]
denken
die
[Musik]
das lange habe ich auf meinem nokia das
nokia freundlich schönsten weißen
gewesen ist
nein jetzt kommt die hürde jetzt vom
finale teller kommt nochmal wir machen
das so wie die oma und sich zwei
gebracht hat mit meiner oma oder andreas
baum machte apfelstrudel gemacht werden
habt ihr noch hemd oder t-shirt vom
titel kann ich klein noch weiter auch
nicht zu schade
nix da der aufwand in meinem buch es
auch schon erledigt